let's see if I can make corporate
restructuring exciting so I'm gonna take
a break up from Black Mirror for a
little bit just for my own sanity hey I
think I don't know how some people binge
this show and not just sink into the
worst depressions of their lives so
there are more black marrow reviews
coming but I've got this ones and I
tomorrow will be my Q&A response because
I'll have hit 10,000 subscribers by then
and then after that I might get back to
black marrow though I might have
something else in there but anyways it's
coming back taking a couple days off
from it though I need to so let's talk
about Warner Brothers and the making of
DC films so we've got the latest bit of
news in regards to that and as you might
have guessed from the intro it's not
it's not anything particularly about the
creative side it's not that they've
announced a new property or a new
director or hire an actor as it's
nothing like that they have assigned a
new head for the at the executive level
to basically manage the the DC films now
this was I have position previously
occupied by John Berwick I talked about
him getting the boot oh maybe about a
month ago or so and him getting the boot
I even said this at the time it he was
basically the scapegoat it's hard to say
that the state of the DC EU could
possibly have been his fault he wasn't
even directly involved into a Wonder
Woman maybe if you wanted to push it you
could blame him to a certain extent for
Justice League specifically but a lot of
the problems with Justice League have to
do with the foundation that the film was
built on and at least as much as the
film as a thing in and of itself so I
still feel like the guy kind of got a
bum rap but he's out and the new guy
that they brought in is a guy by the
name of Walter Hamada now this is a guy
I've never heard of it which is not
shocking there aren't a ton of studio
executives that I know by name but he's
being ported in from new Lyon which is
wholly owned by Warner Brothers and so
he's gonna be taking things over from
where John
bird was now looking at Walter Hamada's
resume on IMDB he's he's been a producer
for a little while pretty much always at
new line which means he's gotten
basically exclusively horror movies
right now now that's no kind of
indicator about what sort of things
interest him as a producer that just
that's linked to the fact that it was at
newline and yo new line yeah their most
successful thing ever might have been
the Lord of the Rings but at the end of
the day they are the house that horror
built they are the house that Freddie
built so you know the horror has always
been their wheelhouse and since the
Warner Brothers absorbed them holy that
that's kind of the niche that now Warner
Brothers has them do so but he has been
doing a fair number of movies for a
while and he doesn't have a ton of
outright stinkers like the last one you
could say that he was involved in that
was a definite flop was probably the
incredible Burt Wonderstone but that's
almost five years ago now so his resume
has been pretty clean since then it's
got a couple of horror movies that I've
never heard of I can go to assume they
went direct to streaming or something
like that but they also look like they
were shot really cheap so they probably
didn't lose money on that but he was the
most relevant thing he's actually got a
certain degree of cinematic universe
experience not a universe nearly as
expansive as you know what DC hopes to
build but he has been a producer on the
conjuring films meaning the conjuring 1
and 2 as well as Annabel and Annabel
creation now regardless of what you
think about the specific strengths or
weaknesses of any of those given films
or of that sort of franchise as a whole
they have been successful they have they
and they've been coherent and so he has
some degree of franchise management
which is something John Berg never had
yeah as much as I kind of like want to
give the guy pass because I feel like
they threw him in the deep end before he
could swim in the first place but
looking at the resumes this guy makes a
heck of a lot more sense than John Berg
ever did because John Berg did not have
a lot in his resume knee didn't have any
like mass franchise work on his resume
now Walter hamada has been working on a
lower scale but he's been working on
something that is more comparable to
what DC and Warner Brothers will want
him to do so it's scaling up something
he already does as opposed to throwing
him in and seeing if he swims so this is
actually kind of a positive move as far
as all as far as I'm concerned now it's
not like I'm suddenly going this means
everything will be great I mean is he's
the executive producer that doesn't mean
that suddenly he's gonna steer the ship
correctly but there isn't a heck of a
lot of red flags about this guy and it
makes a decent amount of sense as far as
these things go I haven't mentioned yet
geoff johns who is basically still on
hand in the same capacity which
supposedly is advisory and guiding the
story I think it's really debatable how
much influence geoff johns has in this
thing at all honestly I think he's a
figurehead I think they trot him out at
Comic Con to you know kid keep the
fanboys on their side I really think he
has very little to do with these
projects if anything maybe they run the
script by him to like to catch
continuity references to stuff or maybe
things like that I can't imagine he's
deeply involved in the production of
these films and I kind of wish they'd
just cut him loose so that he could get
back to the actual comics where I think
he's had a better track record than
being involved in these various
adaptations to whatever degree even is
involved in the first place that being
said it's kind of nice maybe that they
didn't cut him loose if only so that it
doesn't look like they're blaming him
for what happened as much as they decide
to blame John Berg cuz no quick it's
definitely not geoff johns as well cuz
like I said I'm pretty sure they're not
even letting him have any direct
influence over this mess in the first
place but we got a new guy in now and I
mean he's a new guy who on paper
certainly is an improvement on the old
guy in terms of what he's already done
and what he's handled so I I'm not at a
point where I'm suddenly like positive
about the DC EU and Warner Brothers
handling of it but I'm not accumulating
more negatives which in and of itself is
kind of impressive and actually they
seem to be doing the one major thing
that I think they needed to do which is
slow the hell down because so much of
what went wrong with this universe as a
whole and some of the specific movies in
it I mean easily you can see how this
impacted Batman V Superman the decision
to do a team up and try and set up a
whole universe and only the second film
in the in this overall franchise Suicide
Squad which only had six weeks to write
the script
Justice League which they were
constantly trying to fix mid production
all of this is deeply impacted by how
quick they decided they were gonna do
all this stuff early on because before
Batman V Superman even came out they
announced five years worth of stuff with
dates for films probably about half of
which aren't even going to happen at all
now but more recently you know we've got
Aquaman coming out next year
they've given 2019 it has a year for
Wonder Woman to and for Shazam but
that's it they haven't cancelled any of
the other things they had in production
not officially I'm sure some of them
will be but they also haven't announced
anything new and those other things that
don't have years yet they haven't
slapped years on to them which means
vitally they are slowing down they are
waiting to see how the adjustments
they're making actually play out before
they make their next decision on the
next two three four five things they're
gonna do because again regardless of
whether or not you like Batman V
Superman or even if you like Suicide
Squad Justice League or any of it you
cannot deny the fact that you can look
at the production in history and see
very clearly that justice Lee had
pre-production and a script written on
the assumption that Batman V Superman
was going to be a universally acclaimed
film it came out critics hated it and
audiences were deeply divided on it and
they tried to and they almost
immediately went into shooting there was
no time to do any major correctives
to try and adjust for the response they
could only like trying tweak it as they
want to
long because they were moving too fast
and they couldn't slow down and they
seemed to actually be doing that now
John Berg getting removed was announced
about a month after Justice League came
out and under profile it was clear that
that was underperforming pretty early on
early on so they could have thrown him
under the bus gotten someone else in the
next week but they didn't they waited a
month before they jumped him and they
waited about another month before
announcing a replacement these are now
looking like slower more measured more
thought-out decisions being made now
does that mean all the decisions being
made will be good no you can always make
new mistakes but it does appear that the
their biggest most driving force for so
many of their mistakes
ie rushing they seem to be easing off of
and that more than anything gives me
some degree of hope not faith I don't
have faith in Warner Brothers in the DC
eue yet I have faith in patty Jenkins
and Wonder Woman too but that's it that
doesn't extend outwards but I'm now
starting to see a landscape where things
could actually be built and work from
and they can come up with something that
is actually working as opposed to going
all in on something that they don't even
know if people want yet and just praying
that it works which is kind of what they
did for the last few movies up to this
point so yeah oddly enough a new studio
head being assigned and a guy who I've
never heard of somehow manages to give
me hope for the future of the DC EU I
have no clue how that happened how do we
get here but in any case what are your
thoughts on this whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it do all the things like
subscribe I got a podcast and a Twitter
or any mail let it die all that stuff's
down below so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]